oh God here we go the movie opens up in
Bush State Prison a maximum level
facility located in the southwestern
region of the United States it is run by
a twisted Ward named Bill boss known for
his cruel and sadistic ways of dealing
with the inmates he is also a hardcore
cannibal who is always looking forward
to consuming human meat in the opening
scene he is accompanied by his
accountant Dwight Butler as they watch a
gruesome movie called The Human
Centipede 2. after the movie ends Bill
complains that it was very boring and
childish however his assistant Daisy
says that she absolutely loved it she
even goes as far as to say that Bill's
movie preferences are weird this angers
the cruel warden so much that he goes on
a hateful rant claiming that women
should not be allowed to express their
opinions especially if that opinion is
that it's cool for people's faces to be
stitched to people's buttholes after a
while Bill and dwyder summoned to a
scene where an inmate has apparently
killed someone as they walk through the
corridors Dwight reveals the their
prison has higher turnover violence
rates and medical costs than any other
institution in the U.S correctional
system he warns bill that they must take
action to improve these metrics or else
they will be replaced by the governor
however Bill completely disregards his
advice I'm the boss baby you keep your
mouth shut upon arriving at the scene of
the assault they discover that one of
the prison officers has been stabbed by
an inmate for this act bill punishes him
by brutally stomping on his arm he
doesn't stop until the poor man's bone
is exposed however despite this the
inmate vows to repeat his actions once
his bones get healed then all of a
sudden all the prisoners start
disrespecting him from their cells they
all unite in a deafening chorus shouting
that he deserves to be killed because of
his heinous act of violence to the
prisoners when the shouting becomes even
louder an infuriated Bill lashes out at
them by firing his gun aimlessly he also
screams at the top of his lungs that he
deserves respect I'm the bounce damn it
you will respect me baby Upon returning
back to his office Bill proposes the
reintroduction of medieval torture
methods and lists some of them shortly
after Daisy enters the room carrying a
package for Bill and Dwight asks about
its contents Bill reveals that it is a
jar of specially imported dried female
organ pickles which he consumes for
additional strength uh wow not long
after Bill receives a threatening call
warning him that a death squad is coming
to kill him this causes him to panic so
he hastily locks his door and hides
under his desk he believes that the call
is real this time implying that he has
been threatened before Dwight however
remains unfazed and calls the number
back an officer on the other end informs
him that one of the inmates made a prank
call using a fake phone number when Bill
learns of this he is consumed with rage
and orders the officers to hold the
inmate in custody as punishment he
chooses to brutally waterboard three
buckets of boiling water over the
victim's head Billy boss in the bowling
boards baby let's go later that day the
governor arrives to discuss the burning
issue of the prison's escalating
violence he orders Bill and his
accountant to put an end to it and warns
them that they will be fired if they
fail to do so within the next two weeks
in a fit of rage Bill unleashes a tirade
of profanity at the governor as he
departs unable to contain his
frustration despite the governor's
warning Bill remains stubborn and
unwavering in his desire to maintain
control over the prison and impose his
own brand of justice as part of his
Twisted methods of punishments Bill
orders Dwight to send the prisoners out
into the sweltering heat of the yard as
usual the inmates are Rowdy and unruly
ignoring Bill's commands over the
megaphone however when he announces that
one of them will be chosen to undergo
castration most of them fall silent
Billy ball is gonna bite your balls baby
you best look out now he then selects
the inmate who had previously spoken
badly of him and proceeds to carry out
the brutal acts of castration himself
after completing the gruesome procedure
Bill washes his face with the blood of
the victim displaying his utter lack of
remorse and Twisted sense of
satisfaction he even goes on to consume
the victim's test of what the
considering it a source of energy man in
the following scene Bill pays a visit to
the prisoners who are receiving medical
treatment in the clinic along with the
one he castrated himself as he examines
the inmate he informs the doctor that
they will be conducting Mass castration
on all the inmates starting the next day
the bully's balls belong to Bill boss
later that evening Dwight proposes a
solution to improve the prison's
appalling retention and violence rates
to Bill He suggests sowing all of the
prisoners together mouth to butt to form
a massive Human Centipede which would
serve as the ultimate deterrent to Crime
great ideas white yeah Dwight also
reveals that Daisy has spoken to the
film directors of Human Centipede 2 who
confirmed that it is medically accurate
however Bill finds the idea impossible
so he angrily terminates Dwight from his
position in retaliation the latter hurls
profanity Zed bill before departing his
office this enrages the sadistic warden
so much that he grabs his megaphone and
use all sorts of insults and slurs even
though no one is present to hear him
afterwards bill has a terrifying
nightmare in which he is surrounded and
assaulted by the very inmates he has
abused and tormented in his dream he
pleads for Mercy showing vulnerability
and weakness but his cries for help fall
on deaf ears as he is brutally handled
by the inmate he had previously
castrated the next morning Bill wakes up
to the news that Tom 6 the director of
The Human Centipede 2 is arriving at the
prison Dwight also returns and makes a
final plea for Bill to consider his idea
for a human centipede as a way to deter
crime and violence in the prison he
promises to quit his job himself if it
does not work upon Tom's arrival the
discussion about the human centipede
unfolds Tom presents a detailed report
prepared by a surgeon from Amsterdam to
demonstrate the medical accuracy and
feasibility of the centipede idea the
prison doctor examines the report and
confirms its validity further explaining
how the centipede could work this
finally convinced his bill and he says
yes in the next scene Bill decides to
show the inmates the previous two Human
Centipede movies as a warning for what
is to come once the movie ends he enters
the room and discloses that all the
prisoners will be subjected to the same
procedure this Revelation causes an
immediate uproar as the inmates start
reacting violently they Chase bill and
Dwight to their office where Daisy is
beaten unconscious Dwight quickly
summons the armed soldiers as an
emergency backup while Bill escapes by
jumping out of the window Billy boss is
bailing now eventually the backup
arrives and manages to herd all the
prisoners into place once the situation
is calmed down Dwight finds Bill and
informs him of Daisy's severe injuries
however bill is only concerned about
getting medical attention for himself he
then walks out into the prison yard and
announces that it will become a living
hell for everyone later bill begins his
plan to turn the prisoners into a giant
human centipede he goes from cell to
cell tranquilizing each inmate and then
relishing in the sight of the guards
carrying them away the scene then shifts
to the medical ward where Bill explains
the detailed procedure to the doctor
during the operation the doctor mentions
that one of the Prisoners has explosive
diarrhea to which Bill happily suggests
attaching him to the inmate he had
castrated earlier this is so disgusting
moreover incompatible prisoners are shot
and killed during the process as they do
not fit the necessary requirements later
that day Bill and Dwight visit Daisy who
is now in a coma Dwight suggests taking
her to a better hospital but Bill
insists on keeping her close to him the
day after Bill is eager to ensure that
the human prison centipede takes place
in the yard where the governor can
witness it during his visit to the
prison he instructs his accountant to
make the necessary arrangements
overwhelmed with excitement Bill and
Dwight indulge in a bit of role-playing
with Bill pretending to be the governor
and congratulating himself on the idea
however Dwight reminds him that he was
the one who originally came up with the
idea later on Tom arrives at the prison
to inspect the operation of the human
centipede while touring the cells the
group comes across a mentally unstable
inmate who is eating his own excrement
and Desiring to be a part of the
centipede bill is enraged and
immediately shoots him dead as he does
not want anyone to derive pleasure from
this grotesque punishment afterward the
trio proceeds to the operating room
where the surgery is in progress Tom
watches as the death row inmates are
being mutilated and sewn together for
this so-called special project he
becomes nauseated and vomits due to the
horrific side a few days later the
governor returns to the prison to find
that bill and Dwight are looking
extremely pleased with themselves he
inquires what they have done to make
such a drastic change in their attitude
to which Bill explains that they have
accomplished something great and unique
the governor has then led to a large
yard where a 500 person centipede is
displayed before him bill is extremely
proud of his creation but Dwight is
heartbroken when he finds that Daisy has
been accidentally sewn into the
centipede on top of that they have also
created a human Caterpillar by suturing
together death row inmates and those
with life sentences however unlike the
human centipede these prisoners limbs
have been amputated rendering them
immobile and resembling a caterpillar oh
my God the governor is completely
appalled by what he Witnesses following
this they take him to the clinic room
where an inmate whose prison sentence
has been pleaded his staying Bill takes
this opportunity to showcase the
post-minor injuries the prisoners
sustain implying that it is a humane way
to punish them however the governor is
horrified by what he sees and he decides
that bill and Dwight should be punished
with the death penalty sensing the
danger Bill attempts to shift the blame
to his accountant but the governor is
having none of it as soon as he leaves
Bill realizes the gravity of the
situation
and considers committing the unthinkable
the next second he changes his mind
though and turns the gun towards Dwight
blaming him for everything but just as
he is about to pull the trigger the
prison doctor walks in and begins
laughing at their failed attempts Bill
filled with rage shoots the doctor and
kills him on the spot on the other hand
the governor after some contemplation
returns to the prison with an unexpected
change of heart he now believes that the
controversial centipede punishment is
just what the United States needs and
even claims that it could boost his
chances of being elected as the
president before leaving the governor
congratulates Bill who has played a key
role in making the centipede punishment
a reality overwhelmed with joy Bill and
Dwight celebrate their Victory fully
aware that their jobs are now secure
skin in it y'all however as Dwight tries
to claim credit for the idea Bill
quickly silences him by shooting and
killing him so that he can take all the
credit for himself didn't see that
coming in the final scene we see Bill
standing undressed looking out over the
Monstrous centipede screaming with
ecstatic Joy at his successful
accomplishments I'd just like to take a
serious moment to say that I don't
endorse stuff like this I don't endorse
it at all I can't stand it I don't want
it I don't
be a real thing I hate it subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching